a small uncomfortable bed a place where  one-third of humans don't get enough  sleep lack of sleep can lead to many  health problems and tragically only  about 55 percent of couples sleep in the  same bed every night here an epic  struggle occurs nightly and sleep itself  is on the brink of extinction the  mustachioed male defends his territory a  stubble faced male is stunned a  relentless barrage is unleashed heat  eaters on the precipice if he should  fall the chances of survival are slim  sensing danger he awakens is made  something must be done for their sleep  to survive they must work together to  evolve their habitat their strategy  create a calm and cozy nest with ample  space for spreading their wings they  planet was soft yet supportive materials  that cradle their battle weary bodies  nighttime at last sleep has been saved  [Music]